كانوا يأملون أن يكون من الأفضل أن يكون
سر 19 قد فعل أسوأ ما في الأمر
ولكن
16 شهرًا في و محمد باتل
وفريقه المسعفين
في معركة جديدة أكثر خطورة.
ما فعله متغير دلتا لتغطية
هنا تسبب في الكثير من الفوضى
هناك عدد كبير من المرضى الذين
يعانون من انخفاض مستويات الأكسجين
بشكل كبير يوميًا ،
لاحظ علماء جنوب إفريقيا الذين يتتبعون دلتا
أنها تهيمن على الإصابات الجديدة
في غضون أسابيع فقط ، يأخذنا باتيل إلى منزل
جنوب المدينة ،
مرحباً صباح الخير حيث
تمزق دلتا العائلات التي
تمزق من خلالها  سكان البلاد غير الملقحين إلى حد كبير ،
تم تطعيم أقل من واحد في المائة من سكان جنوب إفريقيا بشكل كامل
، يعاني المريض البالغ من العمر 67 عامًا من انخفاض حاد في
مستويات الأوكسجين ،
وسنساعدك في ذلك ، فهناك مرضى
يعانون في المنزل لأنهم غير قادرين
على الحصول على أسرة في المستشفى
لا توجد أماكن في المستشفى
ولا توجد أجهزة تهوية متوفرة ،
إنها فوضى تمامًا كانت الموجة الثالثة
بالفعل
أكثر تدميرا وأكثر إرهاقا بكثير
منذ أشهر حتى الآن طلبت CNN الوصول
إلى المستشفيات
ولكن تم رفضنا لذلك تم إخفاء التأثير الحقيقي
لموجة دلتا الوحشية هذه
إلى حد كبير عن الأنظار ولكن
CNN حصلت على هذا الفيديو المزعج من
غرفة الطوارئ
في مستشفى جوهانسبرج
ينتظرون أنهم في أماكن متباعدة وهم
في مقصورات
الأطباء مثقلون بالممرضات ليس لديهم عدد
كافٍ من
الأسرة وماذا ينتج عن ذلك في
مناطق الانتظار هذه بالمستشفى
إنها الفوضى التي أراد كبير الأطباء
التحدث عنها
كشف ما يسمونه منطقة الحرب  مثل
الظروف
اتفقنا على إخفاء هويتهم
لأنهم كانوا خائفين من انتقام
الحكومة
في الأيام الأخيرة قالوا إن الجثث
لا يمكن لفها
بالسرعة الكافية لإفساح المجال للمرضى ،
وهناك مرضى
يموتون أثناء انتظارهم لرؤيتهم
أثناء انتظارهم للذهاب إلى الجناح
لأن الموارد
تغمرها هجمة المرضى
وكيف لا  قبعة تجعلك
تشعر بالعجز ولكن أيضًا
تقريبًا
إزالة الحساسية أننا نفعل
كل ما في وسعنا
ولكن لا يزال فريق باتيل غير كافٍ
غالبًا ما يتم تحويله من المستشفيات التي بها
مرضى في حالة حرجة
يبحثون لساعات للعثور على سرير لذلك
قامت مؤسسة خيرية
تسمى هدية المانحين ببناء
هذه العيادة الميدانية المكونة من 20 سريراً
والمزودة بأطباء
وممرضات متطوعين في أقل من خمسة أيام يمكن
لكل سرير أن يمنح المريض
المريض فرصة
ديفيد ماكنزي سي إن جوهانسبرج